[Music]
ready to give your mind a workout and
have a go with these 10 brain pieces to
test your mental sharpness if you're new
to our channel hit the red button down
below subscribe how many threes can you
see some brain teasers require you to
look very closely like this one how many
threes can you see ready for the answer
if you said 19 give yourself a high five
there are eight threes in the phone
number two threes on the keypad because
eight has been replaced three threes in
the time two threes in the battery power
and three of the letters in the contacts
name have been replaced four threes as
has the letter I on the number 14
if you don't only include the actual
symbol 3 then there are two more
occurrences in the network signal and
Wi-Fi signal both of which show three
bars train jacks people were losing
their minds over this train track
illusion when it went viral online how
is it possible for the two train tracks
to look like different links when
they're on the table but then line up
the same sides in place on top of each
other this is an example of the gestural
illusion from 100 years ago if you move
the top corner of the lower piece to
line up with the bottom corner of the
top piece the longer side and shorter
side are brought in to contrast light
switch there are three light switches
outside a closed door you have to figure
out which one controls the light inside
the room behind the closed door you can
only go into the room once to check
here's a clue you have to use more than
just your sense of sight here's the
answer
turn on two touches for ten minutes then
turn one of them off go straight into
the room if the light is on the switch
that is still on controls it if the
light is off feel the bulb if it's warm
the switch you just turned off controls
it if it's cold the switch that was
always off controlled it clever huh cork
bottle and coins ready for another one
this brainteaser test your ability to
think of alternative solutions to a
problem you have an empty wine bottle a
cork and a small coin you place the coin
inside the bottle and put the cork into
the neck how do you get the coin out
without taking out the cork
breaking the bottle here's a hint you
can do something else to the cork apart
from pulling it out here's the answer
you push the cork inside the bottle and
then shake out the coin screws math
puzzle
this fruit math puzzle looks like it's
simply testing your ability to add up
it's reasonably easy to figure out the
values of each of the fruit apples are
10 bananas are four coconuts or two so
when you work out the final line of the
puzzle you might automatically add up to
four coconut ten for an apple and four
for a banana to get 16 but look closely
there's only half a coconut and only
three bananas in the bunch
not four so the answer is 1 plus 10 plus
3 equals 14 face and coffee beans some
brain teasers ask you to find hidden
things within images like this one can
you spot the human face within the
coffee bean these kinds of puzzles
require close attention to detail and a
systematic approach to searching every
aspect of the picture
did you see the base it's on the bottom
left only one engine people managed to
see it so don't feel bad if you don't
elephant legs take a look at this
picture and tell us how many legs this
elephant has if your answer for you
might want to look again the feet and
legs aren't where they should be optical
illusions play with our perception of
the world we look at a picture of
something familiar and see what we think
ought to be there but when we look
closer we discover that it's actually
white different yellow but there are
certain puzzles that adults struggle
with but children will fall quickly like
this National Geographic brain game
which 80% of kids under 10 solve which
way is the bus traveling it seems
impossible to answer as the front and
back was the same but you need to think
about what is missing there are no doors
so that means they must be on the other
side in the US and countries where you
drive on the right the bus should be
traveling toward the left join the dots
this 9 dot puzzle is mind-boggling how
do you draw four continuous straight
lines that connect all the dots without
taking your pen off the paper
psychologists and philosophers have used
this puzzle to show how to unlock the
mind and problem solving what you have
to do is think outside the box
literally we automatically assumed the
Lions can extend beyond the boundary of
the dot but there's nothing in the
question that says you can't so you can
connect all nine dots by extending the
line at two points the bottom left and
pop right how should a dog wear pants
we're ending with a bit of fun the
internet went crazy deciding between two
options half the dog wore pants
Maxim's deputy editor asked Twitter
after tens of thousands of retweets and
like 81% went with pants on two legs the
image became a meme with lots of funny
versions like if a snake wore pants or
an axe or a man what do you think how
for the dog wear pants how many did you
solve let us know in the comments and
give our video a big thumbs up
[Music]